au milieu de la centaine de voitures de
collection des moulins café par dizaines
certains se fixe au mur
d'autres sont illustrés ou colorés et à
chaque époque une nouvelle innovation
vient faciliter la vie domestique et
apporter un peu plus de bien-être
on trouve ainsi des machines à coudre
des radios découperez premier arts
ménagers fabriqués par peugeot ou encore
ce petit mix un robot amovible mais le
plus étonnant c'est cette machine à
laver manuel datant de 1926 grâce à
cette machine est assez simple vous
mettiez votre linge dans le tambour vour
fermiers le tambour ensuite vous aviez
préparé grâce au feu
le chauffage de l'eau que vous pompiers
dans le bac une fois que le l'âge était
en place et l'eau chaude remonte aide à
vous tourner la manivelle pour pouvoir
faire tourner le l'âge exposer ses
appareils dans ce musée n'est pas
insolite puisque ce sont les outillages
et les arts ménagers qui ont fait la
renommée de la marque au lion
les premiers accessoires peugeot sont
apparus 200 ans avant les voitures quand
on parle du musée de l'aventuré peugeot
on pense musée automobile
or ce n'est pas que l'automobile est
souvent la première impression quand on
arrive ici cette saison ils ont fait
tout ça j'en reviens pas mais ils ont
fait ça en raison qui fait ça il ya
vraiment tellement de choses à découvrir
que on a voulu le mettre en avant et le
mettre en lumière grâce à cette
exposition c'est toute la dynastie
peugeot que l'on peut découvrir ou
redécouvrir l'exposition se tiendra
jusqu'en janvier 2017